it's dawn it's dark and you don't know
what kind of weather is waiting for you
outside your tent it doesn't matter
anyway in rain hail sleet snow
blistering heat you're on the front
lines shovel in hand wearing over 20
kilograms of gear battling against
nature to save the environment on a good
day you might plant 2,000 trees in a
ten-hour shift but imagine if you had to
do this every day for the next 570
thousand years this is what if and
here's what would happen if we planted
one trillion trees it's true
tree planting is no picnic bears bugs
blisters unpredictable terrain
unpredictable weather up north it
wouldn't be uncommon for a tree planter
to pee on their own hands to keep them
from freezing
tree planting is undoubtedly one of the
world's hardest jobs so why would anyone
do it because if they didn't life would
be much worse for everyone since 1900
births average temperature has risen by
one degree that doesn't sound like much
but just wait till you feel it if our
planet becomes just 2 degrees hotter
than it was in the 20th century heat
waves flooding crop failure and animal
extinction will be commonplace doing
nothing about it would just be reckless
demonstrating an extreme indifference
not just a human life but to all life on
Earth
you might even call it second-degree
murder
some ideas that have been put forward
for cooling the planet include a giant
space umbrella to shield the earth from
the Sun or a giant space mirror to
reflect sun rays back into space
meanwhile back on earth we've already
got trees that absorb the harmful carbon
emissions that warm our planet while
also expelling oxygen so that we can
breathe problem is we just don't have
enough of them to do the job while the
world is currently home to roughly 3
trillion trees we lose about 10 billion
of them every year and as you might
expect we've become more efficient at
stripping our forests than we are at
replanting them as a consequence 20% of
the planet's greenhouse emissions are
caused by deforestation compared to 14%
by transportation if we planted a
trillion trees we could offset a
decade's worth of those emissions time
that we desperately need but it will
truly require an international effort to
realize this goal if every human on
earth planted just 150 trees we could
meet our one trillion tree goal quite
easily but that's just not very
realistic and while the world's tree
planters work long hard days to pick up
the slack there still aren't enough of
them to get the job done in time
a study at Yale University concluded
that if we continue our current rate of
deforestation without planting more
trees our planet will be completely
treeless within 300 years already it's
been calculated that the world has lost
half of its trees since the last ice age
before we revisit the space umbrella
idea let's consider some of the more
feasible options that are on the table
tree planting drones for example can
plant up to 100,000 trees a day the
equivalent of about 50 veteran tree
planters and while a lot of students
take up tree planting as a lucrative
summer job the more innovative ones have
found other ways to cash in but whether
we do it by drones or by robots it's
time to bring out the big guns in this
battle for our planet planting a
trillion trees is still far ahead in our
future
do you know what our world would look
like without them well that's a story
for another what-if
[Music]